The new guy had been there for a month, and he was coming to meetings all the time. And the meetings were on Zoom, but he never turned on his camera. One of his co-workers, Phil, says that wasn't a big deal. Lots of people do that. This was a tech startup.
这个新人来了一个月了，一直都在参加会议。会议是在 Zoom 上开的，但他从不打开摄像头。他的一个同事菲尔说这没什么大不了的。很多人都这样。这是一家科技创业公司。
Maybe it's just engineers. Maybe it's our company culture. I always have my camera off.
也许这只是工程师的习惯。也许这就是我们的公司文化。我总是关着摄像头的。
But then his fourth week on the job, the new guy turned it on.
但到了他工作的第四周，新人打开了摄像头。
And then that's when I was like, what the? Like, who is this guy?
然后我就想，搞什么？这人是谁啊？
And when you say, who is this guy, why? What were you seeing versus what you were expecting to see?
当你说“这人是谁”时，为什么呢？你看到的是什么，而你预期看到的又是什么？
Well, so when I interviewed him, he had his camera on. And literally, he looked different, like physically just different.
嗯，我在面试他的时候，他开了摄像头。他看起来确实不一样，从外貌上看就是不一样。
Also, during the job interview, every time this guy would answer a question, he'd give this big smile.
而且在面试过程中，这个家伙每次回答问题时，都会露出灿烂的笑容。
It was almost as if he was tying a bow around his answer, and this pleasant smile.
就好像他在回答问题的同时还系上了一个蝴蝶结一样，带着这种愉快的笑容。
He was charming. This guy on the Zoom, no pleasant smile. No smile at all. In fact, just the opposite. He was sort of a scowling, dark presence. But there's another part to it.
他很有魅力。但 Zoom 上这个家伙没有这种愉快的笑容。根本就没有笑容。事实上，恰恰相反。他看起来有些愁眉苦脸，阴沉沉的。但这还有另一个原因。
The other part of it was-- I'm trying to find the most PC way to say this, but-- so like he's Indian.
另一个原因是——我正在努力找一种最政治正确的说法，但他确实是印度人。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
And so there-- you know, there was a part of me that, like-- I'll put it this way. I'm Asian American. I've had Caucasian friends mention to me, hey, that guy over there, he looks exactly like you. And I'm like, dude, that guy does not look like me at all, you know?
所以……你知道，我心里有一部分觉得……我这样说吧。我是亚裔美国人。我有一些白人朋友跟我说，“嘿，那个人看起来和你一模一样。”我就想，老兄，那个人跟我一点也不像，你知道吧？
Yeah.
是啊。
So I sort of had that thought, too. And I felt a little bit guilty about it, to be honest. I was like, oh, I was like-- I guess this is the right person, and it's kind of on me.
所以我也有过这种想法。老实说，我对此感到有点内疚。我就想，哦，我猜这就是那个人，我也只能这样认为了。
Wait, wait. But are you saying that you thought, oh, wait a second, he looks really different, but maybe I just can't tell with an Indian person. Like, am I racist? Is that what you're saying?
等等，等等。你是说你当时想，“哦，等等，他看起来确实很不一样，但也许我只是无法分辨印度人。”你是说你在想“我是不是种族主义者”吗？
Yes, but I'm not racist. Yeah, I'm saying like, maybe--
是的，但我不是种族主义者。是的，我是说，也许……
But I'm saying, that was the question in your head.
但我是说，那确实是你脑海里的问题。
Yeah. Yeah. Exactly.
对，没错。正是这样。
Phil kept all this to himself, though there was another person who noticed there was something different about the new guy. That somebody else was Phil's boss, Subra, who also supervised the new guy, who hired him, and who is Indian. Subra was struck by one detail in particular.
不过菲尔把这一切都藏在心里，尽管还有另一个人也注意到这个新人有些不对劲。那个人就是菲尔的老板苏布拉，他也是新人的主管，面试并录用了他，而且苏布拉本人也是印度人。苏布拉对一个细节印象特别深刻。
So the person who we interviewed, he had curly hair.
我们面试的那个人，他留着卷发。
Dark, curly hair, memorably curly hair. Like, this was the thing that hit Subra about the guy the first time he interviewed him.
深色、卷曲的头发，令人难忘的卷发。这就是苏布拉第一次面试他时最在意的地方。
His hair is similar to one of the Indian saints, Sai Baba-- bushy hair, curly. And then once you see it, you cannot really forget it.
他的头发和一位印度圣人赛巴巴很像——浓密的卷发。一旦你见过，你就真的忘不掉。
Hmm.
嗯。
But then, when he was in our meetings, he was not showing his hair. He was only showing up to his forehead. He was not showing his hair.
但当他参加我们的会议时，他没有露出他的头发。他只露出了额头。他不让人看他的头发。
Wow. I have to say, you really have to position yourself close to the camera for it not to see your hair.
哇。我必须说，你真的得贴着摄像头坐，才能让人看不见你的头发。
Yeah. I mean, I did that. I asked him, could you please show your complete face?
是的。我是这么做的。我问他：“你能把你的整张脸露出来吗？”
And that's when Subra saw the new guy didn't have that big, bushy, curly hair.
也就是在那时，苏布拉发现那个新人并没有那头又大又浓密的卷发。
And then I asked him, did you get a haircut? And he said, yes, I had a haircut. Then I doubted myself.
然后我问他：“你剪头发了吗？”他说：“是的，我剪了头发。”然后我开始怀疑自己了。
He doubted himself. He thought, he'd been interviewing so many job applicants lately. Their tech company was rapidly expanding. He thought maybe he was remembering wrong.
他怀疑自己了。他心想，最近面试了那么多求职者。他们的科技公司扩张得很快。他以为可能是自己记错了。
Phil, meanwhile, knew none of this. Then one day, Phil was in a Zoom meeting with the new guy. And for a second time, the new guy flipped on his camera. And surprise.
与此同时，菲尔对这一切一无所知。后来有一天，菲尔和那个新人在 Zoom 上开会。新人第二次打开了摄像头。结果让人大吃一惊。
And it turned out to be the guy from the interview. Instantly, there he is, right? And then came utter confusion of, what the hell's happening here?
结果发现这根本不是面试的那个人。他突然就在那里了，对吧？然后就陷入了彻底的混乱：这到底是怎么回事？
Oh, my god. OK, now there are two different people. I don't know what to think. In the back of my head, I was like, there just can't be two people.
天哪。好了，现在是两个不同的人了。我不知道该想什么。我心里暗想，这不可能有两个人吧。
OK, so not long after that, Subra is meeting with Phil about some stuff. And Subra asks him something like, the new guy, does he look different to you? Phil says it was a huge relief to even be asked the question, to know that somebody else saw it. And they figured out what happened.
后来没过多久，苏布拉找菲尔谈一些事情。苏布拉问他：“新人看起来跟你不一样吗？”菲尔说，能被问到这个问题让他感到如释重负，至少有人和他有同样的发现。他们终于弄清楚发生了什么。
A very qualified guy with bushy hair and a big smile interviewed for the job, and then a less charming, shorter-haired guy showed up for the job. It turns out he wasn't all that qualified, didn't actually understand the tasks he was given. They fired him. Though I should say, Subra told me, if he could have done the work, he'd have kept him. He didn't care who he was.
一个拥有浓密卷发和灿烂笑容、非常称职的人面试了这份工作，然后来上班的却是一个缺乏魅力、头发较短的家伙。结果证明那个人根本不够格，甚至不理解分配给他的工作任务。他们解雇了他。不过我得说，苏布拉告诉我，如果他能干活，他会留下他的。他才不在乎他是谁。
And I bring all this up because I think it's so interesting, that period. It was like days when both Subra and Phil, they knew the truth, they saw it with their own eyes, couldn't be anything else, but each of them talks himself out of it, doubts the evidence that's right in front of him. Phil says a big reason that he doubted the truth that one guy would interview for the job, and then another guy would show up, was that he just didn't know that that kind of thing was on the table as a possibility.
我提到这一切是因为我觉得那个时期很有趣。那是苏布拉和菲尔都知道真相的日子，他们亲眼所见，事实确凿，但他们每个人都在试图说服自己，怀疑眼前的事实。菲尔说，他怀疑会有“一个人面试，另一个人入职”这种情况，很大程度上是因为他压根没想到这种事还会发生。
The thought of this guy not being that person is just so crazy. Why would I even think that, you know?
这家伙不是面试的那个人，这念头太疯狂了。我怎么会这么想呢，你知道吧？
Yeah, that's not a thing that happens.
是啊，这种事不可能发生。
Yeah, like who would even think to do this?
是啊，谁会想到做这种事呢？
Well, today on our program, we have other stories of people looking squarely at the truth, staring right at it, and they still find it hard to believe what's right in front of their eyes, for all kinds of reasons. Our power to deny the reality of what we're seeing is like one of our superpowers as a species. And if you doubt that, well, just stick around.
那么，在今天的节目中，我们还有其他关于人们直面真相的故事，明明真相就在眼前，他们却因为各种原因难以置信。我们否认所见现实的能力，就像我们作为物种的一种超能力。如果你不信，那就听下去吧。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
来自芝加哥 WBEZ 电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act 1, She Blinded Us with Science. So our program today is about not believing what is right in front of you. When you're on the other side of that, when you can see what other people are refusing to see, what do you do? What's your move?
第一幕，她用科学蒙蔽了我们。所以我们今天的节目是关于“不相信眼前的事实”。当你站在事态的另一面，当你能看到别人拒绝看到的东西时，你会怎么做？你有什么打算？
Well, Chana Joffe-Walt talked to a woman in that situation about how she came to see what others couldn't and about what she did with that knowledge. Quick heads up that this story talks about research into sexual assault.
查娜·乔菲-沃尔特采访了一位处在这种境况下的女性，了解她是如何发现别人看不到的东西的，以及她是如何利用这些知识的。预警一下，这个故事涉及有关性侵犯的研究。
I knew one thing about her when I first called.
我第一次给她打电话时，只知道她的一件事。
Tell me your name and, I guess, your name and what you are most famous for.
告诉我你的名字，还有你最出名的是什么。
My name is Mary Koss. I feel like an athlete who had their biggest success when they were very young, and then spent the rest of their life trying to do important things, but never achieving the initial level of recognition.
我叫玛丽·科斯。我觉得自己就像一名运动员，在非常年轻的时候取得了最大的成功，然后用余生试图做些重要的事情，却再也没能达到最初的认可度。
OK, so she's not going to mention the one thing she's known for. I will, but give me a minute. I want you to hear the way she discovered it. She was at a new job, 27 years old. She was a brand new professor, Psychology Department, 1976.
好吧，她没有提到她最出名的那一件事。我会提的，但请给我一点时间。我想让你听听她是怎样发现这件事的。那时她在找新工作，27岁。她是 1976 年心理学系的一名新教授。
On my first day at Kent State University in Ohio, I'm walking in a double door. So I'm going in one side, and there's a man rushing out of the other door. He stops me, because he recognizes that I'm the new hire. And he said, I just got a grant turned down, and they turned it down because I'm a man. So I want you to put your name on it, and we'll resubmit it, and we'll get funded.
在我到俄亥俄州肯特州立大学的第一天，我走进一道双开门。我从一侧进去，一个男人正从另一侧冲出来。他拦住我，因为他认出我是新来的员工。他说：“我的科研基金申请被拒绝了，因为我是个男人。所以我想让你在上面签个名，我们重新提交，这样就能拿到拨款了。”
Wait a second. Is there a hello, who are you, my name is, first?
等等。难道不应该先说“你好，你是谁，我叫什么”之类的吗？
No. No. I had, frankly, no idea of who he was. So I had the presence of mind to say, well, I probably should read the grant before I put my name on it.
没有。我坦白说，根本不知道他是谁。所以我保持理智说：“好吧，在签名之前我可能应该先读一下这份申请。”
So she read it. And when she read it--
所以她读了。当她读到的时候——
I thought, oh, wow. The grant proposal was that graduate student women would dress up in a back room in different sizes of padded bras, and then they would go out and interact with a male student who did not know that they weren't just a regular student.
我想，哦，哇。那份拨款申请是让研究生女学生在一个后室里穿上不同罩杯的加厚胸罩，然后走出去与一名毫不知情的男学生互动。
And then afterwards, this male student would be given a questionnaire and asked to make ratings, among which were, how rapable did you find this woman? How likely would she be to have sex with you? And if she were raped, how culpable would she be? Then, of course--
事后，这名男学生会拿到一份调查问卷，并被要求进行评分，其中包括：你觉得这个女人有多容易被强奸？她有多大可能会跟你发生性关系？如果她被强奸了，她有多大责任？然后，当然——
What?
什么？
Of course, you know, these same grad students--
当然，你知道，这些同样的研究生——
What?
什么？
went-- would go back in the room, and then the next student would get the same grad student coming out in a gigantic padded bra. And then, I suppose, that they were going to have some conditions where they came out bound to have no breasts at all.
回去之后……会再次走进那个房间，然后下一个学生也会看到同一个穿戴巨大加厚胸罩的研究生出来。然后，我想，他们可能还会设置一些条件，比如让她们出来的时候完全不戴胸罩。
I love that what Mary is thinking about at this point in the story is what the control group would be for this experiment. Moving forward, I just want to note the difference between me, a squawky non-scientist, jaw dropping at this premise, and Mary Koss, who is now a veteran scientist, who apparently no longer wastes any energy on indignation.
我很喜欢玛丽在这个故事节点上思考的问题，即这个实验的对照组应该是什么。我想指出的是：我作为一个大惊小怪的非科学家，对这种前提感到震惊，而玛丽·科斯现在是一位资深科学家，似乎已经不再把精力浪费在愤怒上了。
I wanted to dwell for a few moments in the absurdity of someone thinking to study the rapability of grad students wearing padded bras. Mary, instead, began making a reasoned argument against it. Federally-funded scientific research, she says, should have policy implications.
我想在有人提议研究戴加厚胸罩的研究生有多大“可强奸性”的荒谬上多停留片刻。但玛丽反而在进行有理有据的反对。她说，联邦资助的科学研究应该具有政策影响。
And the only policy implication I can see in this is that the federal government would have to make available funds for minimizer bras.
我能看出的唯一政策影响就是联邦政府必须为缩小胸罩提供资金。
Wait. That's the problem with it? It's not that you're asking male students how rapable their fellow female students are?
等等。这就是问题所在吗？不是因为你在问男学生他们的女同学有多容易被强奸？
At the time, what I found most offensive was that he was looking for the causes of rape in breast size.
当时，我觉得最冒犯的是他在胸部大小中寻找强奸的原因。
Yeah, why not butts or hips?
是啊，为什么不是屁股或臀部呢？
[LAUGHING] I know. Maybe today, if I thought about it more deeply, I'd find other aspects of it extremely troubling. I mean, it certainly does--
[笑] 我知道。也许今天，如果我深入思考，我会发现它的其他方面也极度令人不安。我是说，这确实……
There's plenty. There's a lot to pick from in this particular example.
有很多。在这个特定的例子中有很多可以挑剔的地方。
Yeah. Even that long ago, I thought, well, rape victims aren't responsible for what happens to them, rapists are.
是啊。即使在那么久以前，我就想：好吧，强奸受害者对发生的事不负责任，强奸犯才负责。
But Mary Koss was on the market for a research project herself. She read through this one, and there was one question that she was interested in.
但玛丽·科斯自己也在寻找研究项目。她读完了这一份，其中有一个问题引起了她的兴趣。
When I looked at his proposal, and it said, "--and we'll also do a survey of college students to see how much rape is going on among them," that was a totally unique idea. So I thought, that's the great opportunity in this application. It's not the padded bra part. Lose the padded bras, and let's work on the survey part.
当我看到他的建议时，上面写着“……我们还将对大学生进行一项调查，看看他们之间发生了多少强奸案”，那是一个完全独特的想法。所以我心想，这才是这份申请中的巨大机会。不是加厚胸罩那部分。去掉加厚胸罩，让我们做调查部分。
She moved forward on the survey part, without her male colleague. Mary Koss would ask college students about their experiences with sex and sexual violence. Up to that point, there had been virtually no academic studies of sexual aggression.
她撇开那个男同事，继续推进调查部分。玛丽·科斯开始询问大学生关于性和性暴力的经历。在那之前，几乎没有关于性侵犯的学术研究。
Federal crime statistics did actually measure incidents of rape, but Mary says the survey asked, essentially, have you been raped? So few women said yes that researchers would conclude that rape is rare or, quote, "clearly an infrequent crime." The whole approach didn't make sense to Mary.
联邦犯罪统计确实测量了强奸事件，但玛丽说，调查实质上是在问：“你被强奸过吗？”以至于说“是”的女性太少，研究人员得出的结论是强奸很少见，或者引用原文，“显然是一种不常发生的犯罪”。整个方法在玛丽看来都讲不通。
You don't ask somebody, are you an alcoholic? Well, first of all, who would want to be an alcoholic? They'd say no. Second of all, alcoholic's a medical diagnosis, so they don't know what the criteria for being an alcoholic are. For those reasons, you translate it into behavioral terms like, how many drinks do you have in a day? I decided to do that same thing with asking questions about sexual victimization and perpetration.
你不会问别人“你是酒鬼吗？”首先，谁愿意承认自己是酒鬼？他们会说“不”。其次，“酒鬼”是一个医学诊断，他们不知道成为酒鬼的标准是什么。基于这些原因，你必须把它翻译成行为术语，比如“你一天喝多少杯酒？”我决定用同样的方法，询问关于性受害和性施暴的问题。
Have you had someone use force or threaten to harm you to have sexual intercourse when you didn't want to? Have you had a man penetrate you against your will? Mary Koss will readily admit now that these are very straight and 1970s gendered questions. She looked at how rape is defined legally and built her questions around it. She'd ask women, have you had this experience? What about this?
你有没有遇到过有人使用武力或威胁伤害你，以强迫你发生性行为，而你并不想那样？有没有男人违背你的意愿侵犯过你？玛丽·科斯现在会爽快地承认，这些是非常直接且带有 1970 年代性别倾向的问题。她研究了法律如何定义强奸，并围绕它构建了问题。她会问女性：“你有过这种经历吗？那这种呢？”
They would turn around and say, yes, that happened to me. But no, I've never been raped.
她们会回答说：“是的，那发生在我身上。但我不，我从未被强奸过。”
So when women actually would describe what happened, their experiences would often line up with the legal definition of rape. But when you'd ask them, were you raped, they would say no.
所以，当女性真正描述发生的事情时，她们的经历往往符合强奸的法律定义。但当你问她们“你被强奸了吗”，她们会说“没有”。
Exactly.
没错。
So it's sort of like if somebody asks you, were you robbed, and you say, no, I wasn't robbed. And then if you say, did someone come to your house and take all your things without your permission? They'd say, oh, yes, that did happen?
这就像如果有人问你“你被抢劫了吗”，你回答说“不，我没被抢劫”。然后如果对方问“有人到你家把你所有的东西都拿走了，而且没经你同意吗？”她们会说“哦，是的，确实发生了”。
Exactly. Exactly. And then if you said to them, was that robbery or larceny? And they'd say, oh, I have no idea. All I know is my stuff is gone. I realized there has to be something called the unacknowledged rape victim-- somebody who has been raped, as defined under the law, but does not use that term, did not perceive her experience that way.
没错。正是这样。如果你接着问她们“那是抢劫还是盗窃？”，她们会说“哦，我不知道。我只知道我的东西没了。”我意识到一定存在一种所谓的“未被承认的强奸受害者”——那些在法律定义下已被强奸，但并没有使用那个术语，也没有那样看待自己经历的人。
In the late '70s and early '80s, when Mary Koss was conducting her survey, when her colleague was proposing putting students in padded bras, the popular understanding of rape was this-- rape is something that happens in a back alley with a stranger. Someone jumps out of a bush, or breaks into your house, or hides in your car.
在 70 年代末和 80 年代初，当玛丽·科斯进行调查时，当她的同事提议让学生穿加厚胸罩时，对强奸的普遍理解是这样的：强奸是发生在小巷里、有陌生人参与的事情。有人从灌木丛里跳出来，或者闯入你的家，或者躲在你的车里。
If you were deeply unlucky-- and, I guess, if your boobs were too big-- you could be targeted by a rapist. A rapist was a person you do not know-- a monster, criminal. Rape was not something that happened with your boyfriend, or your relative, or a crush, or a friend, or a guy at a party.
如果你特别倒霉——我想，如果你的胸部又太大的话——你可能成为强奸犯的目标。强奸犯是你根本不认识的人——是怪物、罪犯。强奸不是发生在你男朋友、亲戚、暗恋对象、朋友或聚会上的某个男人身上的事情。
The experiences Mary was hearing from women in her survey lined up with the criminal definition. They would describe being physically forced to have sex with a boyfriend, being blackout drunk, being coerced, being on a date. And the majority of these women--
玛丽在调查中从女性那里听到的经历与犯罪定义相符。她们会描述在约会中被强奸、烂醉如泥、被胁迫、被男朋友强制发生性关系。而这些女性中的大多数——
Found it to be a bad experience, found it to be one of the worst experiences of their lives. They just didn't call it rape.
认为那是一次糟糕的经历，认为那是她们一生中最糟糕的经历之一。她们只是没把它称为强奸。
Mary Koss finished her survey, sat with her results, stared at them, ran the numbers again. Mary found that one in four female respondents had an experience that met the legal definition of rape or attempted rape-- one in four.
玛丽·科斯完成了调查，看着结果，盯着它们，再次核算了数据。玛丽发现，四分之一的女性受访者有过符合强奸或企图强奸法律定义的经历——四分之一。
Several year later, in 1987, she repeated the survey-- a national survey this time, not just her campus, but 32 college campuses, more than 6,000 undergraduate students. Same finding-- one in four. As reporter Robin Warshaw wrote at the time, Mary Koss had revealed that rape was more common than left-handedness, or heart attacks, alcoholism. Mary had revealed something that was so far from the reality we'd been living in, she found she needed new words. She started calling this acquaintance rape, or hidden rape.
几年后，在 1987 年，她重复了这项调查——这次是全国性调查，不仅仅是她的校园，而是 32 所大学，超过 6000 名本科生。结论一样——四分之一。正如记者罗宾·沃肖当时所写，玛丽·科斯揭示了强奸比左撇子、心脏病、酗酒更常见。玛丽揭示了一些远远超出我们所生活现实的东西，她发现她需要新的词汇。她开始称其为“熟人强奸”或“隐性强奸”。
Hidden rape, like hidden from the very people who it happened to.
隐性强奸，就像对受害者本人隐瞒了一样。
It was hidden from the very people it happened to. And because it was hidden from them, it had to be hidden from the rest of society, too.
它对受害者本人是隐瞒的。正因为它对受害者是隐瞒的，它也必然对社会其他部分是隐瞒的。
The term for this that caught on was date rape. This is the thing I knew about Mary Koss, that she's the person that came up with the concept of date rape, who measured it-- one in four. This is what she achieved early in her career that she will forever be known by and is tired of talking about.
为此流行开来的术语是“约会强奸”。这就是我所知道的关于玛丽·科斯的事——她是提出“约会强奸”概念的人，是那个测量出“四分之一”数据的人。这就是她在职业生涯早期取得的成就，她将永远因此而闻名，并且已经厌倦了谈论它。
Mary's not what I expected, for a groundbreaking 20th century social scientist. She's punchy. She's fun to talk to.
玛丽并不像我所预期的那种 20 世纪开创性的社会科学家。她很有冲击力。和她交谈很有趣。
I was in New York talking to her. She was in her home in Arizona with a recording engineer. And the recording engineer kept being worried about how animated Mary would get when she talked, that she was moving around too much, making noise. And Mary starts just sort of gently trolling the engineer to me.
当时我在纽约和她通话。她在家乡亚利桑那州，旁边有一位录音工程师。录音工程师一直担心玛丽说话时会太激动，担心她动来动去制造噪音。玛丽开始半开玩笑地向我调侃这位工程师。
I'm so sorry.
我很抱歉。
I--
我——
It's so sensitive.
它太敏感了。
I just got the instructions that I can't touch myself.
我刚收到指示说我不能触碰自己。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And I wasn't planning to do that in any big way, but--
我本来没打算那样做，但是——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
No, it's OK. It's like, every little movement--
不，没关系。这就像，每一个小动作——
Mary is so comfortable talking to people about things most people find difficult to talk about that, back when she published her big findings, back in the 1980s, she was not at all expecting what happened next-- the backlash. People questioned her. They questioned her terms. They invented new terms. Date rape became rape hype.
玛丽在和别人谈论大多数人觉得难以谈论的事情时是如此从容，以至于在 80 年代她公布自己的重大发现时，她完全没预料到接下来会发生什么——反弹。人们质疑她。他们质疑她的术语。他们发明了新的术语。“约会强奸”变成了“强奸炒作”。
This response was a cover story in The New York Times Magazine, "How Rape Hype Betrays Feminism," New York Magazine, "Crying Rape," The Atlantic Monthly, "Feminism's Identity Crisis." Newsweek asked, "Sexual Correctness, Has It Gone Too Far?" Mary Koss says one show booked her to talk about her research and surprised her with Hugh Hefner and Playboy bunnies to debate with her.
这种反应成了《纽约时报杂志》的封面故事，标题是“强奸炒作如何背叛女权主义”；《纽约杂志》刊登了“哭诉强奸”；《大西洋月刊》刊登了“女权主义的身份危机”。《新闻周刊》问道：“性正确，是不是走得太远了？”玛丽·科斯说，有一个节目预订了她谈论她的研究，却出其不意地安排了休·海夫纳和花花公子兔女郎来和她辩论。
It's a drumbeat. Everyone was repeating the same things. It's the researcher calling these rape, not the person.
这是一阵鼓点。每个人都在重复同样的话。这是研究者在称之为强奸，而不是当事人。
They're basically saying, you're making it up.
他们基本上是在说，你是编造出来的。
Exactly. And it just incensed me. The reality of my work was being discounted. I was being disbelieved. I was being blamed as a bad researcher.
没错。这让我非常愤怒。我工作的现实被贬低了。我不被相信。我被指责为一个糟糕的研究者。
Did you draw the parallel between what was happening to you and what happens to rape victims?
你有没有把你身上发生的事和强奸受害者身上发生的事联系起来？
No. I had-- I haven't thought about it that way up until this moment, actually.
没有。事实上，直到这一刻，我都还没那样想过。
Did you doubt yourself?
你怀疑过自己吗？
No.
没有。
Lots of people were looking at Mary Koss' data and not believing what was right in front of their eyes. But there was a reason for all the backlash. Mary Koss' research was getting attention. It was catching on.
许多人看着玛丽·科斯的数据，却不相信摆在眼前的事实。但所有反弹都有原因。玛丽·科斯的研究引起了关注。它正在流行起来。
In the years following her studies, there was a real cultural shift. The term date rape became ubiquitous. College campuses launched education programs on sexual assault. Students organized Take Back the Night events. Rape prevention programs started up. Women's shelters were opened. Congress passed the Violence Against Women Act in 1994, a major federal response to rape and domestic abuse. Mary Koss testified before Congress.
在她研究后的几年里，确实发生了文化转变。“约会强奸”这个词变得随处可见。大学校园发起了关于性侵犯的教育项目。学生们组织了“夺回夜晚”活动。强奸预防项目开始了。妇女庇护所开了起来。国会在 1994 年通过了《反针对妇女暴力法》，这是联邦政府对强奸和家庭虐待的主要回应。玛丽·科斯在国会作证。
And today, right now, we all think of rape differently because of Mary Koss. And she watched that shift take place over decades. And as she did, Mary waited for the numbers to go down. There's now a whole field of research on sexual assault. And Mary told me a couple of years ago, she thought, I should check in on the latest data.
今天，此时此刻，因为玛丽·科斯，我们所有人对强奸的看法都不同了。她看着这种转变在几十年间发生。当她这样做时，玛丽等待着数据下降。现在关于性侵犯的研究已经形成了一个完整的领域。玛丽在几年前告诉我，她心想，我应该看看最新的数据了。
I was not expecting the results, because the rate of reporting to police is identical to what it was 40 years ago. Do more women realize they've been raped today? Well, you would certainly think so, wouldn't you? But the answer to that is, no, more women don't.
我没预料到结果，因为向警察报案的比率和 40 年前一模一样。今天有更多的女性意识到自己被强奸了吗？好吧，你当然会那样认为，不是吗？但答案是，没有，并没有更多。
Oh.
哦。
And I just felt, as a scientist and as a wannabe do-gooder, why weren't we making things better?
作为一名科学家和一名想做好事的人，我只觉得，为什么我们没能让情况好转呢？
I found this remarkable. I first reached out to Mary Koss early in the MeToo movement, in 2018, because at the time, I was interviewing lots of women who were reading the news and reassessing their own experiences, asking themselves, that thing that happened, was that rape? Assault? They told me, I never thought of it that way. I didn't have a word to describe it.
我发现这很引人深思。我第一次联系玛丽·科斯是在 2018 年“我也是”运动早期，因为当时我采访了许多女性，她们读着新闻，重新评估自己的经历，问自己：“发生在那件的事，是强奸吗？是侵犯吗？”她们告诉我：“我从没那样想过。我没有词来描述它。”
And I heard this multiple times, I never called it rape, which is literally the title of a book about Mary Koss' work from 1988, I Never Called It Rape, a book that was published 34 years ago. Even though Mary Koss helped change the way society as a whole sees rape on this large scale, that didn't change the way individual people saw what happened to them.
我多次听到这句话：“我从没把它称为强奸”，这实际上是 1988 年一本关于玛丽·科斯著作的书名，即《我从没把它称为强奸》，这本书在 34 年前就出版了。尽管玛丽·科斯帮助改变了整个社会大规模看待强奸的方式，但这并没有改变个人看待发生在自己身上事情的方式。
The numbers Mary Koss came up with have been replicated multiple times over the years by her, by other researchers. Sometimes it's one in four, sometimes one in five. Mary spent most of her career hoping that if we change the way victims understood rape, there would be less rape. But lately, her focus has changed.
玛丽·科斯得出的数字多年来被她自己和其他研究人员多次重复验证。有时是四分之一，有时是五分之一。玛丽的大部分职业生涯都在希望：如果我们改变受害者对强奸的理解，强奸就会减少。但最近，她的关注点改变了。
Mary now believes we will not see any change until perpetrators understand what they are doing as rape. But getting perpetrators to identify their behavior, that's so much harder. Mary says, you can see in surveys, even in person one-on-one, men will say--
玛丽现在认为，除非施暴者明白他们正在做的就是强奸，否则我们看不到任何改变。但要让施暴者识别自己的行为，那要难得多。玛丽说，你可以在调查中看到，即使是面对面，男人们也会说——
I don't know why I'm here. I've been accused of raping somebody. I have no idea why. You can open the Arizona statutes. You can point them to the Chapter 14 offenses, which are sexual assault.
“我不知道我为什么在这里。我被指控强奸了某人。我完全不知道为什么。”你可以打开亚利桑那州的法律法规，你可以指给他们看第 14 章的犯罪行为，也就是性侵犯。
You can underline the one that talks about taking advantage of someone when they're incapacitated from alcohol and unable to consent or stop what's happening. And their face just goes white, because they had no idea. But now, you're showing them a law book that says that they raped somebody. They could take a polygraph test, and they could pass it because they honestly don't believe that what they did was wrong.
你可以给谈到“利用某人在因酒精而丧失行为能力且无法同意或停止发生的事情”那一条画线。他们的脸一下子就会变得惨白，因为他们完全不知道。但现在，你是在给他们看一本法律书，上面写着他们强奸了某人。他们可以通过测谎仪测试，并且能通过，因为他们真心不相信自己所做的是错误的。
How is it possible that we cannot know things for so long? The very first question I asked Mary Koss, what is she famous for, Mary didn't care for that question, which is fair. It's not a great question.
我们怎么可能这么久都不知道一些事情呢？我问玛丽·科斯的第一个问题是她因何出名，玛丽不喜欢那个问题，这很公平。那不是一个好问题。
But I think I get now why this was an especially tedious one for her. Mary Koss is known for discovering something decades ago that we still don't know. She was able to see so much of what was hidden from the rest of us, but this, our ability to not know things, is the one thing she missed.
但我现在明白为什么这对她来说是一个特别令人厌倦的问题了。玛丽·科斯因几十年前发现了一些我们至今仍不知道的东西而闻名。她能看到很多对我们其他人隐藏的东西，但这个——我们不知道事物的能力——却是她唯一忽略的东西。
Chana Joffe-Walt, she's one of the producers of our show. Coming up, kids going to school in what used to be a big hardware store. And there's one subject, when it comes up, the kids cannot face. They only pretend to agree with their teacher. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
查娜·乔菲-沃尔特，她是我们的节目制作人之一。接下来，孩子们在曾经是大型五金店的地方上学。有一个科目一提到，孩子们就无法面对。他们只是假装同意老师的观点。稍后由芝加哥公共广播电台继续我们的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "My Lying Eyes," stories of people staring at the truth, but it's hard to take in for all kinds of reasons.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是“我的谎言之眼”，讲述人们盯着真相，却因各种原因难以接受的故事。
We've arrived at Act 2 of our program. Act 2, How the Other Side Leaves.
我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，另一边如何离开。
So according to a recent UN estimate, something like 5 and 1/2 million people have already fled Ukraine. For a while, a bunch of them were ending up in Tijuana, Mexico, at the border, trying to get into the United States with, of course, people from lots of other countries, who also would like to get into the United States. They're there because they couldn't get visas to fly directly into the United States, and Mexico didn't require a visa.
根据联合国最近的估计，大约有 550 万人已经逃离了乌克兰。有一段时间，他们中的许多人涌向墨西哥蒂华纳的边境，试图进入美国，当然还有来自许多其他国家的人，他们也想进入美国。他们在那是因为他们拿不到直接飞往美国的签证，而墨西哥不需要签证。
Anyway, the situation has changed some since the Ukrainians first showed up at the border. But in some important ways, it has not changed at all. We sent James Spring down there in the second week of April. James has done a bunch of stories for us from the border. He's no stranger to the situation down there, and yet he still had a hard time believing what he was seeing. Here he is.
总之，自乌克兰人第一次出现在边境以来，情况已经发生了一些变化。但在某些重要方面，它根本没有改变。我们在 4 月的第二周派詹姆斯·斯普林去了那里。詹姆斯为我们做过不少关于边境的报道。他对那里的情况并不陌生，但他仍然难以相信自己所看到的。他在这儿。
I've spent a lot of time at migrant shelters in Tijuana, and I've never seen anything like this. You can tell the difference a block away. The day I visited, it was all so orderly.
我在蒂华纳的难民收容所呆过很多时间，但我从未见过这样的情况。隔着一个街区你就能看出区别。我去的那天，一切都那么井然有序。
This Ukrainian shelter is housed in a shiny, 4-acre sports complex called the Unidad Deportivo Benito Juarez. Security is tight, Mexican cops are posted on the corner, and Americans in lime green safety vests are directing traffic. A packed school bus heads off to deliver a load of Ukrainians to the border crossing.
这个乌克兰人收容所设在一个光鲜亮丽的 4 英亩运动中心，名叫贝尼托·华雷斯体育中心。安保严密，墨西哥警察驻守在街角，身穿柠檬绿安全背心的美国人在指挥交通。一辆满载的校车出发将一批乌克兰人送往边境检查站。
At the front gate, security directs me to a sign-in desk. There's a big whiteboard with shift schedules. Everybody seems to have specific jobs. There's even a media coordinator.
在正门，保安指引我到签到处。那里有一块大白板，上面写着轮班表。每个人似乎都有具体的工作。甚至还有一名媒体协调员。
You're waiting to get escorted in?
你在等 escorted 进去吗？
Yeah.
是的。
You're press? OK.
你是新闻界的？好的。
I'm given a 15-minute slot to be escorted around the shelter with a volunteer. He sets a timer on his phone. We walk.
我得到 15 分钟的时间，由一名志愿者陪同参观收容所。他在手机上设了一个计时器。我们开始走。
Inside the complex, it's clean. And there are tons of American volunteers and just resources-- easy-up stations with cooked food, and information sheets, and people helping to get refugees in line to board the next bus. The Ukrainians don't really want to talk with me, which I get.
综合设施内很干净。有成群结队的美国志愿者和各种资源——带有熟食的快餐站、信息单，还有帮助难民排队登上下辆大巴的人。乌克兰人其实不太想跟我说话，这点我能理解。
Thank you, though.
谢谢。
They've put on some hellish miles here at the end of a hellish month.
在这悲惨的一个月结束时，他们在这里走了不少地狱般的里程。
Do you guys speak English?
你们说英语吗？
They're mostly slumped in folding chairs or propped up against their wheeled suitcases. The person who organized all of this is a tall, young guy who's wearing black jeans, and a white t-shirt, and a cap with an American flag on it. His name is Vlad. He's 24. He's from Ukraine, but he lives in San Diego where he runs a Christian ministry.
他们大多数人瘫坐在折叠椅上，或者靠在带轮子的行李箱上。组织这一切的人是一个身材高大的年轻人，穿着黑色牛仔裤、白色 T 恤，戴着印有美国国旗的帽子。他叫弗拉德。他 24 岁。他是乌克兰人，但住在圣地亚哥，在那里经营一个基督教事工。
I never been in Mexico before. It's my first time. I've been here three weeks already, and my plan was to be here--
我以前从没来过墨西哥。这是第一次。我已经在这里呆了三周了，我的计划是呆在这里——
When he arrived, there was no official infrastructure to help the Ukrainians, so Vlad put one together himself. He was able to tap into a network of other churches in the US that wanted to help, and they made contact with officials in Tijuana. The city donated the use of the sports complex and provided some beds. Everything else comes from churches and private donations.
他刚到时，没有官方基础设施来帮助乌克兰人，所以弗拉德自己组建了一个。他能够利用美国其他愿意帮忙的教堂网络，并与蒂华纳的官员取得了联系。市政府捐赠了这个运动中心的使用权，并提供了一些床位。其他一切都来自教堂和私人捐款。
The Mexican government said it's the best what they've seen, ever, like how we're working with refugees. Because, as you can see, it's clean. We have volunteers here. We have good kitchen here. And as you know, they open for us Chaparral Border only for Ukrainian refugees. So only Ukrainian can come to this authorized bus and go through the border. And the CBP officer is processing them there.
墨西哥政府说，这是他们见过的最好的，就是我们如何处理难民问题。因为如你所见，它很干净。我们这里有志愿者。我们这里有很好的厨房。如你所知，他们只为乌克兰难民开放了 Chaparral 边境。所以只有乌克兰人可以乘坐这辆授权大巴通过边境。海关及边境保卫局官员正在那里处理他们。
The day I was there, Vlad said there'd be between 500 and 800 refugees moving through this shelter. They have a whole system. Each Ukrainian refugee is assigned a number. They scan a QR code for an app that tracks their place in line, and their progress is logged by volunteers at every stop along their final journey to the US. It's like if a factory and a military operation had a baby.
我去的那天，弗拉德说会有 500 到 800 名难民通过这个收容所。他们有一整套系统。每个乌克兰难民都被分配到一个号码。他们扫描一个追踪排队位置的应用程序的二维码，志愿者会记录他们在前往美国的最后旅程中每一站的进度。这就好比一家工厂和一次军事行动生的孩子。
Normally, it had been taking a day and a half to process the Ukrainians through the shelter and into the US. But on this day, it's only taking about eight hours total-- eight hours. It strikes me hard that there are some migrants not very far away from where we're standing who've been waiting-- let's just say longer-- for their shot at being able to step onto American soil.
通常情况下，处理乌克兰人通过收容所进入美国需要一天半的时间。但在这一天，总共只需要大约八个小时——八个小时。我深受震撼，因为在离我们站的地方不远的地方，有一些移民已经等了——我们就说更久吧——等着他们踏上美国土地的机会。
The next day, I went to a different migrant shelter not far away, Agape Mision Mundial. It's also a church-based shelter in Tijuana. It has about the same number of people as the Ukrainian one, but these are migrants mainly from Central America and Mexico, a few from Haiti. I wanted to visit Agape to see what they knew about what was happening at the sports complex with the Ukrainians, if they had any thoughts or feelings about it.
第二天，我去了不远处另一个移民收容所，Agape Mision Mundial。它也是蒂华纳的一家教堂附属收容所。那里的人数和乌克兰人的差不多，但这些主要是来自中美洲和墨西哥的移民，还有一些来自海地。我想参观 Agape，看看他们对乌克兰人在运动中心发生的事情有什么了解，他们对此有什么想法或感受。
Agape is up a dirt road. It's right between a junkyard and a cemetery. And it's not very big, maybe the size of like two Olive Garden restaurants. And I'll just come out and say it. The place has a very different vibe than the Ukrainian compound.
Agape 在一条土路上。它正处于一个垃圾场和一个墓地之间。它不太大，大概相当于两家橄榄花园餐厅的大小。我就直说了。这个地方的氛围和乌克兰人的大院完全不同。
Gracias.
谢谢。
A young Mexican girl opens the gate to let me in. It's all pretty loosey goosey. And it's dense with people, like the same number of people as at the Ukrainian shelter, but in a much smaller space. I ask if I can speak with somebody in charge, and I'm directed to a Honduran migrant named Antonio.
一个年轻的墨西哥女孩打开门让我进去。一切都挺随意的。里面很拥挤，就像乌克兰收容所的人数一样，但在一个更小的空间里。我问是否可以和负责人谈谈，他们指引我去找一位名叫安东尼奥的洪都拉斯移民。
I ask him if I need to sign in or anything. Nope. I ask him, do you have security here? He says, yes, me and the pastor. And sometimes, there's a guy named Ulises, another migrant. Antonio goes to fetch the pastor for me.
我问他是否需要签到之类的。不用。我问他，你们这里有安保吗？他说，我和牧师。有时还有一个叫尤利西斯的家伙，也是个移民。安东尼奥去帮我找牧师了。
People crowd a narrow corridor that leads past a bunch of open doorways to some rooms that just, like-- look, the entire place is just rough. Beyond the rooms, there are a lot of tents in the yard. It's lunchtime, and there are people cooking stuff all over the place-- gas camping stoves inside rooms. And out in the yard, there are open wood fires underneath a plastic tarp roof.
人们挤在一条狭窄的走廊里，走廊穿过一堆开着的门洞，通向一些看起来——看吧，整个地方简直是一团糟。房间外面，院子里有很多帐篷。正是午餐时间，到处都有人在做饭——房间里放着燃气露营炉。在院子里，塑料布屋顶下有露天的木火。
They cook their own food, and they have-- well, not refrigerators, just--
他们自己做饭，他们有——好吧，不是冰箱，只是——
Pastor Albert is from Puerto Rico. 25 years ago, he started Agape as a church and rehab center, but he turned it into a shelter. Agape is not supported by a network of churches.
阿尔伯特牧师来自波多黎各。25 年前，他创办了 Agape 作为教堂和康复中心，但他把它变成了一个收容所。Agape 没有得到教堂网络的支持。
The government donates some food every month. But other than that, donations are pretty rare. The migrants have to mostly buy everything that they need for themselves. Some have jobs. Some get money from relatives in the states.
政府每个月捐赠一些食物。但除此之外，捐款非常少见。移民们大多必须自己购买所需的一切。有些人有工作。有些人从在美国的亲戚那里拿钱。
People don't move out of the shelter very quickly. In the last month, only one person from Agape, a migrant named Danny, was legally processed into the US after staying there for most of a year. I asked Pastor Albert if he's been to the Ukrainian shelter. Turns out that he has. He volunteered there. He knows all about it and how the Ukrainians were being processed into the United States in just a few days. I tell him that the previous day, the processing time was only eight hours.
人们离开收容所的速度并不快。在上个月，只有一名来自 Agape 的移民，一个叫丹尼的人，在住了大半年后被合法处理进入美国。我问阿尔伯特牧师是否去过乌克兰人的收容所。结果他去过。他在那儿做过志愿者。他非常清楚关于它的一切，以及乌克兰人是如何在短短几天内被处理进入美国的。我告诉他，前一天，处理时间仅为八个小时。
Oh, so now it's express, very express.
哦，所以现在是快车，非常快。
Does that irritate you a little bit?
这会让你觉得有点受刺激吗？
Well, basically, it looks all over like discrimination. Discrimination. Don't get me wrong, I'm 100% for the United States to allow the Ukrainians to enter. I know they've been through a lot. I know they have suffered a lot. And I know that they're saying, OK, they're entering as refugees, because they're suffering a war.
嗯，基本上，到处看起来都是歧视。歧视。别误会我，我 100% 支持美国允许乌克兰人进入。我知道他们经历了很多。我知道他们遭受了很多苦难。我知道他们说，好的，他们作为难民进入，因为他们在遭受战争。
Now, what I don't understand is, well, when organized crime and drug cartel declare a war on civilians, declares war on that city and says, every 13-year-old has to be part of our cartel, and they're going to go on the front lines to shoot and fight against the other cartel, if you don't agree to it, you got three days to leave the city. I have immigrants here that that's what they're going through.
现在，我不理解的是，当有组织犯罪和贩毒集团对平民宣战，对那个城市宣战，并说每个 13 岁的人都必须成为我们集团的一部分，如果他们不答应，就会被派到前线去与其他集团战斗，如果你不同意，你有三天时间离开这座城市。我这里的移民经历的就是这些。
But the UN, United States, don't consider that as war against civilians. It only applies if it's one government against another government in war for you to enter as a refugee. That doesn't make sense.
但联合国、美国并不认为那是针对平民的战争。这只有在政府与政府之间的战争中才适用，你才能作为难民进入。这不合理。
The US government sees the Ukrainian refugees through a different lens than they do the Latin American migrants. The people at the border from Central America and Mexico are mostly seeking asylum with a pathway to citizenship, a way to live permanently in the United States. The Ukrainians, though, they just need a place to wait out the war.
美国政府通过不同的视角看待乌克兰难民，而不是拉美移民。来自中美洲和墨西哥的边境人员大多寻求避难，以获得公民身份，寻找永久居住在美国的途径。而乌克兰人，他们只需要一个地方熬过战争。
They're being accepted into the US through a process called humanitarian parole, which allows them to stay for up to 12 months. For over two years, US officials closed the border to nearly all immigration because of COVID, but then they found a way around it for the Ukrainians. As Pastor Albert summarizes it, I guess white people aren't contagious.
他们通过一种称为“人道主义假释”的过程被美国接受，这允许他们停留长达 12 个月。两年多来，美国官员因为新冠病毒关闭了边境，几乎禁止了所有移民，但后来他们为乌克兰人找到了解决办法。正如阿尔伯特牧师总结的那样，“我猜白人不会传染。”
I'd really been hoping to bring Pastor Albert along with me back to the Ukrainians' compound to get his first impressions. But since he'd already seen it and is too busy anyway, he suggests that I take one of the migrants instead, see what they think of it. He introduces me to a young woman, named Mayra, from Michoacán in Mexico.
我真的很希望能带阿尔伯特牧师和我一起回到乌克兰人的大院，看看他的第一印象。但因为他已经看过了，而且无论如何都很忙，他建议我带一个移民去，看看他们怎么想。他把我介绍给一个名叫玛拉的年轻女人，她来自墨西哥的米却肯州。
While she's waiting to request asylum in the US, she teaches school to kids in the shelter. She seems enthusiastic about the idea of seeing the Ukrainian shelter. She says to the pastor--
当她在等待向美国寻求庇护时，她在收容所教孩子们上学。她对参观乌克兰收容所的想法似乎很热情。她对牧师说——
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
"So go with him?"
“所以和他一起去？”
Si.
是的。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
I'll get my jacket, she says. Mayra arranges to leave her son with a relative and is back in a minute flat with a coat and a backpack. I ask her about the Ukrainians and what she's heard about their shelter.
“我带上外套，”她说。玛拉安排把儿子留给亲戚，一分钟内就穿好外套，背上背包回来了。我问她关于乌克兰人的事，以及她听到的关于他们收容所的事。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
Not much, she says. I hear they get a lot of support, but really not much more than that. I'd like to see it. She seems genuinely curious. OK, I say.
“没多少，”她说。“我听说他们得到了很多支持，但其实没什么其他的了。我想看看。”她看起来真的很好奇。好吧，我说。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
We'll do it.
“我们会这么做的。”
Vamos.
走吧。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
We drive. Mayra says that she's been at the Agape shelter for seven months. She's really invested in the kids she's teaching, wants to instill good values in them. She starts her classes really early, at 7:00 AM. Are you serious, I say? She thinks it's good for them.
我们开车前往。玛拉说她在 Agape 收容所住了七个月了。她真的投入在教那些孩子里，想给他们灌输好的价值观。她开始上课真的很早，早上 7 点。你是认真的吗，我说？她认为这对他们有好处。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
I like to be very punctual, she says. I tell my students, as a teacher, I have to set an example for you. If I want you to get up early, then I have to get up early myself. The saying goes, God helps those who rise early.
“我喜欢非常准时，”她说。“我告诉我的学生，作为老师，我必须为你们树立榜样。如果我想让你们早起，那么我自己也必须早起。俗话说，天道酬勤。”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
"We have to be optimists." Her optimism seems particularly profound, given everything that's happened to her. She was a schoolteacher back in Michoacán, too, but her family also owned avocado farms and avocado packing facilities.
“我们必须保持乐观。”她的乐观似乎特别深刻，考虑到她身上发生的一切。她在米却肯州时也是一名学校老师，但她的家庭也拥有牛油果农场和牛油果包装设施。
When the cartels arrived and started to demand more and more protection money, Mayra's family couldn't afford it. Three of her uncles were kidnapped, never to be seen again. The cartel had made it clear that the next time they came, if her family didn't pay up, they'd kill everyone. So she and two dozen of her relatives-- cousins, kids, aunts-- all fled here together to Tijuana.
当贩毒集团到达并开始要求越来越多的保护费时，玛拉的家庭付不起。她的三个叔叔被绑架，再也没有回来。贩毒集团已经明确表示，下次再来时，如果她的家庭不给钱，他们就会杀光所有人。所以她和两打亲戚——堂表兄弟、孩子、阿姨——都一起逃到这里来到蒂华纳。
The cartel continues to send threats, audio messages on WhatsApp. Mayra plays a couple of them for me. One of them says, we know where you are now in Tijuana. We're going to fuck up your whole family if you don't cooperate.
贩毒集团继续发送威胁，WhatsApp 上的音频信息。玛拉为我播放了其中的几条。其中一条说：“我们现在知道你在蒂华纳哪里了。如果你不合作，我们要搞死你们全家。”
It's 11 minutes to the other shelter. We drive along the border wall to get there.
距离另一个收容所有 11 分钟路程。我们沿着边境墙行驶到那里。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
Uh-huh.
嗯。
Here's the entrance, I say.
“入口就在这儿，”我说。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
What do you think?
“你觉得怎么样？”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
Really nice, actually, she says. Really nice.
“真的很好，事实上，”她说。“真的很好。”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
"Seriously, I don't believe it. Can they send me here?"
“说真的，我不相信。他们能送我到这儿来吗？”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
How's your Ukrainian, I say?
“你的乌克兰语怎么样，”我说？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
Well, she says, I'm not that dark skinned, like maybe she could blend in. It's a joke.
“好吧，”她说，“我没那么黑，就像也许我可以混进去。”这是一个笑话。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
And the sports complex, she says, do they use it just for them? Or is it like-- and then she just says, I can't believe it. Our assigned press escort appears. She's a Ukrainian-American volunteer from a church in California. She seems smart and capable. It's the same deal as yesterday-- 15 minutes for the tour.
“还有那个运动中心，”她说，“他们只为他们用吗？或者它就像……”，然后她只是说，“我不敢相信。我们的指定媒体陪同人员出现了。她是一名来自加州教堂的乌克兰裔美国志愿者。她看起来既聪明又能干。和昨天一样——15 分钟的参观时间。
Yeah. So they have a kid's center. For little kids inside, they have little toys, and Legos, and stuff like that. There's a coloring station for the older kids. And then there's--
是的。所以他们有一个儿童中心。给里面的小孩子，他们有小玩具、乐高积木之类的东西。大孩子有一个涂色站。还有——
The woman points out this little area for the Ukrainians' dogs with some kennels. I translate what she's saying to Mayra, who's pretty wide-eyed now.
那个女人指出了这个供乌克兰人养狗的小区域，里面有一些狗舍。我把她的话翻译给现在睁大眼睛的玛拉。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
Oh, that too, she says. Cool, as if to say, how nice for them. Mayra asks, where'd all the supplies come from? Donations, the guide says.
“哦，那个也，”她说。很酷，仿佛在说，他们真好运。玛拉问，所有这些物资是从哪里来的？捐款，向导说。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
And everything over here, those are all donations, she asks?
“还有这边的所有东西，那些都是捐赠的吗？”她问。
Yes. So this is all donations. If anybody needs any clothes, there's shoes, I think. There's toys behind. There's strollers for kids, car seats, anything that's needed.
是的。所以这都是捐赠的。如果任何人需要任何衣服，有鞋子，我想。后面有玩具。还有婴儿车、汽车座椅，任何需要的东西。
All of these things might come in really handy for people who are staying in a place for a long time. But of course, that's not the case with the people coming through this shelter. I ask how much time it's taking today for the Ukrainian refugees to be processed into the US.
所有这些东西对那些长期住在一个地方的人来说可能真的很方便。但当然，通过这个收容所的人不是这种情况。我问今天处理乌克兰难民进入美国需要多少时间。
It's been pretty quick. If they come in in the morning, they're usually gone by nighttime. But there's been times where it takes at least 24 hours.
相当快。如果他们早上进来，通常到晚上就走了。但有时也需要至少 24 小时。
So right now, people are not even really having to sleep in here, because they're moving so quickly.
所以现在，人们甚至不用真的睡在这里，因为他们移动得太快了。
Right. Because you don't know. Your number can get called at any time. So you can go to sleep. We've had people that their number got called, and they look at the board, and they're like, oh, my number, I missed it. Then they have to catch the next bus. It's OK if they miss it, but somebody else gets filled into their spot.
对。因为你不知道。你的号码随时可能被叫到。所以你可以去睡觉。我们曾有人号码被叫到，他们看着白板，然后说，哦，我的号码，我错过了。然后他们必须赶下一辆大巴。如果错过了也没关系，但会有其他人填补他们的位置。
I translate this to Mayra.
我把这个翻译给玛拉。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
Oh, well, she says, what can I say? I guess we'll talk, she says.
“哦，好吧，”她说，“我能说什么呢？我猜我们会谈谈的，”她说。
The fact that the Ukrainians are getting processed so quickly and under humanitarian parole, that's tough for her. She tried to get her dad into the US under humanitarian parole. He had severe diabetes. His leg had been amputated. It was getting worse, and no medical interventions in Mexico were helping. The humanitarian parole claim was denied. Mayra's father died in the Agape shelter in November.
乌克兰人得到处理如此迅速，而且在人道主义假释下，这让她很难受。她试图在人道主义假释下让她爸爸进入美国。他患有严重糖尿病。他的腿被截肢了。病情在恶化，而在墨西哥没有任何医疗干预能提供帮助。人道主义假释申请被拒绝了。玛拉的父亲于 11 月在 Agape 收容所去世。
Thank you, so much. I really appreciate your time today.
谢谢你们，太感谢了。我真的很感谢你今天的时间。
No problem.
没问题。
Mayra and I walked toward the exit, past the chafing dishes of food, past the cases of bottled water, past the walls of clothing and blankets sealed in clear plastic bags, past the smiling American guards at the front gate.
玛拉和我朝出口走去，经过食物保温盘，经过瓶装水箱，经过密封在透明塑料袋里的衣物和毯子墙，经过前门面带微笑的美国警卫。
Thank you, guys.
谢谢你们。
Yes, sir. Appreciate it.
是的，先生。谢谢。
Outside, I point out that the Mexican cops are still posted at the corner, keeping watch.
外面，我指出墨西哥警察仍然驻守在街角，保持警戒。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
What? Really, she says? They get that, too? And people shoot at us from outside the shelter, actual gunfire, and the police are almost never around. How sad.
“什么？真的吗，”她说？“他们也得到那个待遇？”而人们从收容所外面向我们开枪，真正的枪声，警察却几乎从来不在附近。多悲哀啊。
She's not exaggerating. In September, a gun battle outside Agape sent a hail of bullets into the shelter, into a room where children were staying. In December, there were published news reports of armed men threatening shelter migrants.
她没有夸大其词。9 月份，Agape 外的一场枪战向收容所发射了一阵子弹，射入了一个有孩子居住的房间。12 月，有新闻报道称武装人员威胁收容所的移民。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
Mayra says, the way that woman said that they have families waiting for them in the US, well, we do, too. We also have family waiting for us over there, and it's the same. They had to leave their country, we also had to leave or, really, we're forced to leave.
玛拉说：“那个女人说他们在美国家庭等着，好吧，我们也有。我们也有家人在那边等着我们，是一样的。他们不得不离开他们的国家，我们也必须离开，或者说，实际上，我们是被迫离开。”
It's sad, she says. Honestly, it's sad. And it makes me really angry to see it. I'm seeing the comparison. They have chairs, beds, when there are people in our shelter who've been living there for months, sleeping on the ground.
她说，“这很悲哀。老实说，这很悲哀。看到它让我真的很生气。我在进行比较。他们有椅子、床，而我们的收容所里有人已经住了几个月，睡在地上。”
I sleep in a little bunk. I don't even have a mattress. It's just the bare wood. There are people who've been there 10 months, just waiting for a reply from the government. And they don't have the resources. They don't have them.
“我睡在一个小铺位上。我甚至没有床垫。只有光秃秃的木头。有人已经在那里住了 10 个月了，只等着政府的回复。他们没有资源。他们没有资源。”
I've seen so few people, so, so few bringing even a single donation to the shelter. Or, for example, these kids have so many supplies-- Crayons, notebooks, Play-Doh, these learning materials. And our kids, who are here for months, don't have these supplies.
“我见过的人很少，非常、非常少，甚至带一份捐赠到收容所。或者，例如，这些孩子有这么多物资——蜡笔、笔记本、橡皮泥、这些学习材料。而我们的孩子，在这里呆了几个月，没有这些物资。”
And those who are only here for eight hours, they have everything here, everything, everything, all the comforts. They even have the internet. They bring them cooked food. They have everything. The truth is, they don't need it.
“而那些只在这里呆八个小时的人，他们这里有一切，一切，一切，所有的舒适。他们甚至有互联网。他们给他们带去熟食。他们有一切。事实是，他们不需要它。”
Honestly here, I see how literally they don't even open the things they bring them. I think they don't even open it. They don't need it. They're people who simply pass through, and they give them everything. Why?
“老实说在这里，我看到他们甚至不打开带给他们的东西。我想他们甚至不打开它。他们不需要它。他们只是路过的人，他们给他们一切。为什么？”
It made me want to cry, she says. Maybe I'll find me a Ukrainian man and say, let's go. Then she says, ah, but everyone comes with their family anyway.
“这让我很想哭，”她说。“也许我会找个乌克兰男人说，走吧。”然后她说，“啊，但无论如何大家都是带着家人来的。”
No.
不。
No, I tell her. A lot of them are single.
“不，”我告诉她。他们中的很多人是单身的。
Si?
真的吗？
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
Well, then why didn't you introduce me to one, she says? It'd be like my pass, my ticket in.
“好吧，那为什么你不介绍我认识一个，”她说？“那就像我的通行证，我的入场券。”
OK.
好的。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
Let's leave before I start to cry, she says, [LAUGHS], before I get angry.
“让我们离开这里，在我哭出来之前，”她说，[笑]，在我生气之前。
It's not that Mayra doesn't understand what the Ukrainians are going through. She does. It's just that now she's seen that the whole world came together so quickly, and so efficiently, so willingly, to try to help, and they haven't done that for her and for so many others like her. She wishes that people wanted to, because, clearly, they can do a lot when they want to.
并不是玛拉不理解乌克兰人正在经历什么。她理解。只是现在她看到整个世界如此迅速、高效、心甘情愿地联合起来试图提供帮助，但他们并没有为她和那么多像她一样的人这样做。她希望人们愿意，因为显然，当他们想的时候，他们可以做很多事情。
James Spring. Since James was in Tijuana the second week of April, the situation has changed for Ukrainians there. The United States announced that they will no longer be processing Ukrainians at that border, so the shelter that James visited, it's closed.
詹姆斯·斯普林。自从詹姆斯在 4 月的第二周在蒂华纳以来，那里的乌克兰人的情况已经发生了变化。美国宣布他们将不再在该边境处理乌克兰人，所以詹姆斯参观的那个收容所已经关闭了。
In the place of all that, the Biden administration has introduced an even faster, easier process for Ukrainians to enter the United States. It's called Uniting for Ukraine. Refugees from Ukraine can now get a visa to fly directly into the United States. When the shelter for Ukrainians closed in Tijuana, leftover donations and supplies were given away to other migrant shelters and churches in the area.
取而代之的是，拜登政府为乌克兰人进入美国引入了一个更快、更简单的过程。它被称为“团结一致为了乌克兰”。来自乌克兰的难民现在可以获得签证直接飞往美国。当蒂华纳的乌克兰人收容所关闭时，剩余的捐款和物资被分发给了当地的其他移民收容所和教堂。
Act 3, We Did Start the Fire. So this last story is about some kids and a lesson in school, a lesson that their teacher was having some real difficulty getting across, even though it was connected to something that the kids had witnessed with their own eyes. Katie Worth first reported this story for the PBS series, Frontline, and The GroundTruth Project. She got to know these kids and explains.
第三幕，我们确实引发了火灾。所以最后一个故事是关于一些孩子和学校里的一课，一堂老师很难传达的课，尽管它与孩子们亲眼所见的事情有关。凯蒂·沃思首先为 PBS 系列片《前线》和《地面真相项目》报道了这个故事。她了解了这些孩子并进行了解释。
I'd like to introduce you to a seventh grader named Kyson Wilson. Normally, I'd describe him for you, but I'll let him do it.
我想向你介绍一位名叫凯森·威尔逊的七年级学生。通常我会为你描述他，但我还是让他自己说吧。
I look like a little kid, super small. Don't look like I've grown up that much at all. I'm still like a little baby, I think, to myself. I hate my voice, how it sounds. And then everybody is so much taller than me, so it makes me feel small.
我看起来像个小孩子，超级小。一点都不觉得自己长大了多少。我想，对我自己来说，我仍然像个小婴儿。我讨厌我的声音，听起来的样子。而且每个人都比我高得多，所以这让我觉得很渺小。
Do you think that's going to change?
你觉得那会改变吗？
Yeah, I think it'll change soon, and I can't wait.
是的，我觉得很快就会改变，我等不及了。
Kyson's favorite subjects are science and math.
凯森最喜欢的科目是科学和数学。
You had a quiz yesterday, right?
你昨天有个小测验，对吧？
Yes, we did.
是的，我们有。
How did you do?
你考得怎么样？
I got every single question right. I'm the only one that did, I think.
我每一道题都做对了。我想我是唯一一个全对的。
The school Kyson goes to is not his normal school, not anyone's normal school, in fact. Let me explain how he got here. On the morning of November 8, 2018, Kyson and his mom, Kelsey Wilson, were at home in the Sierra Foothills of Northern California, getting ready to start their day.
凯森上的学校不是他正常的学校，事实上，不是任何人的正常学校。让我解释一下他是怎么到这里的。2018 年 11 月 8 日早上，凯森和他的妈妈凯尔西·威尔逊在北加州塞拉丘陵的家中，准备开始他们的一天。
But then Kelsey's husband, who'd already left for work, texted a photo of a fire. It was moving their direction, fast. They needed to evacuate, which Kyson was not happy about.
但随后凯尔西的丈夫，已经去上班了，发来了一张火灾的照片。它正在向他们的方向快速移动。他们需要撤离，凯森对此很不高兴。
So I was asking her, mom, take me to school. I need to keep my perfect attendance.
所以我一直在问她，“妈妈，带我去学校。我需要保持我的全勤记录。”
And I was like, you know what? I'm really sorry about ruining your perfect attendance. I don't think it's a good idea to take you over there.
而我当时想，你知道吗？我很抱歉毁了你的全勤记录。我不认为带你去那里是个好主意。
This is Kelsey.
这是凯尔西。
And then we started packing.
然后我们开始打包。
So we packed a lot of stuff. And when we left, it was pitch black.
所以我们打包了很多东西。当我们离开时，漆黑一片。
Pitch black, because smoke had blotted out the sun. That morning, the most destructive fire in California history, the Camp Fire, had caught near their home in Paradise, California. The whole city evacuated down the same few roads out of the hills, so they were stuck in traffic, which was terrifying. At one point, both sides of the road they were edging down were in flames.
漆黑一片，因为浓烟遮住了太阳。那天早上，加州历史上最具破坏性的火灾“营地大火”在他们位于加州天堂镇的家附近烧了起来。整个城市通过通往山外的几条公路撤离，所以他们被困在交通中，这太可怕了。有一次，他们缓慢行进的道路两侧都在着火。
Kelsey lost contact with her husband, who was taking a different road out of town. For a few frightening hours, they wondered if he was dead. Their house, like nearly every building in Paradise, burned down.
凯尔西失去了与她丈夫的联系，他走了另一条路离开城镇。在那几个可怕的小时里，他们怀疑他是否死了。他们的房子，像天堂镇的几乎每一栋建筑一样，都被烧毁了。
Like a lot of other folks, Kyson and his family resettled in the city at the bottom of the hill, Chico, six people crammed into a 29-foot trailer. The middle school that got set up for the Paradise kids was not a school at all. It was a big-box hardware store that had gone out of business. Kyson gave me a little tour.
像许多其他人一样，凯森和他的家人在山下的城市奇科重新定居，六个人挤在 29 英尺长的拖车里。为天堂镇孩子们建立的中学根本不是学校。它是一家已经倒闭的大型五金店。凯森带我参观了一下。
Where do you eat lunch?
你们在哪里吃午饭？
We eat lunch at the cash registers.
我们在收银台吃午饭。
PE was now in the garden center. The library, Aisle 16, housewares. Principal's office, electrical. And the classrooms--
体育课现在在园艺中心。图书馆在 16 号过道，家居用品区。校长办公室在电器区。而教室——
So the classrooms used to be super small aisles, like, if you went to Walmart, just regular aisles. And our desks used to be shelves.
所以教室以前是超级小的过道，就像，如果你去沃尔玛，就是普通的过道。而我们的课桌以前是货架。
Kyson says his teachers tried lecturing from one end of the aisle, or the other, or somewhere in the middle. It didn't really work.
凯森说他的老师们试着从过道的一头，或者另一头，或者中间讲课。其实没用。
The teachers did not like going down these small, skinny aisles.
老师们不喜欢走这些又小又窄的过道。
So the school eventually took down some of the aisle dividers to make double-wide aisles, added desks and whiteboards, which helped them feel a little more like real classrooms. But it's loud in a way no real school would ever be. The noise of all these kids bounces off the metal roof and back down.
所以学校最终拆掉了一些过道隔板，做成了双倍宽的过道，增加了课桌和白板，这让他们感觉更像真正的教室了。但它响得惊人，是任何真正的学校都不会有的那种响。所有这些孩子发出的噪音撞击金属屋顶并回荡下来。
It's also cold-- 59 degrees. Everyone's in coats. They'd been heating the store with propane. But one day, someone smelled gas. The fire department showed up, and lots of the kids freaked out.
它也很冷——59 华氏度。每个人都穿着外套。他们一直用丙烷加热这家店。但有一天，有人闻到了燃气味。消防队赶到了，很多孩子吓坏了。
Some went catatonic, others called their parents to pick them up. The smell brought them back to the day they'd evacuated Paradise and hearing the sound of propane gas tanks exploding one after another as they fled. After that, the administration just left the heat off.
有些人变得紧张，其他人叫父母来接他们。这种味道把他们带回了撤离天堂镇那天，他们听到丙烷气罐一个接一个爆炸的声音。在那之后，管理部门干脆关掉了暖气。
As it happened, I'd actually shopped in this hardware store before it became a school. I'm from Chico. The day of the fire, my aunt had to evacuate. And I'm also a climate reporter. For the last year, I'd been reporting on what kids are taught about climate change in school. When I found out there was a group of kids who could arguably be called climate refugees set up in a hardware store in my hometown and about to learn about global warming in science class, I had to come home and check it out.
巧的是，在这家五金店成为学校之前，我实际上曾在里面买过东西。我是奇科人。火灾那天，我姨妈不得不撤离。而且我也是一名气候记者。过去一年里，我一直在报道学校里教给孩子们关于气候变化的什么。当我发现有一群可以被称作气候难民的孩子被安排在我家乡的一家五金店里，并且即将在科学课上学习全球变暖时，我不得不回家去一探究竟。
We're learning carbon cycle this week, which was pretty interesting.
我们这周正在学习碳循环，这非常有趣。
Again, here's Kyson.
再说一次，这是凯森。
The carbon is going up and up, and it's getting warmer and warmer. And everybody is just using too much carbon in the world.
碳不断上升，天气越来越暖和。世界上每个人使用的碳实在太多了。
There's strong science connecting climate change to the fire these kids survived, but I wondered if they would see it that way. Paradise is pretty red. Only about half the people in our county think global warming is real, that humans are causing climate change. So I wanted to see how that would play out in this classroom.
有强有力的科学将气候变化与这些孩子幸存下来的火灾联系起来，但我不知道他们是否会那样看。天堂镇相当红。我们县只有大约一半的人认为全球变暖是真的，认为是人类导致了气候变化。所以我很想看看这在教室里会如何表现。
All right, ladies and gentlemen. Thank you, for coming in and getting yourself ready. I really appreciate that.
好了，女士们先生们。谢谢你们进来并做好准备。我真的很感激。
This is Marc Kessler, the science teacher. Kessler has a gentle affect one would expect of a flower farmer, which is what he was before he became a science teacher. He's been worried about climate change since the '90s, was one of the first to put solar panels on his roof. Around school, he was known as Mr. Tesla.
这是马克·凯斯勒，科学老师。凯斯勒有一种人们在花农身上预期的那种温和的氛围，那是在他成为科学老师之前的工作。他从 90 年代起就担心气候变化，是第一批在屋顶安装太阳能电池板的人之一。在学校里，他被称为“特斯拉先生”。
Kessler's approach to teaching climate is really hands-on. One morning, I watched him do a lesson where he had each student pick three spots anywhere on the globe and look up how the average temperatures in those places had changed over the decades.
凯斯勒教气候的方法非常注重实践。一天早上，我看他做了一堂课，让每个学生在全球任何地方选三个地点，查一下这些地方的平均温度几十年来是如何变化的。
You can go anywhere in the world you want. And then you're going to list whether they're increasing, decreasing, or staying the same.
你想去世界上任何地方都可以。然后你列出它们是在增加、减少还是保持不变。
The kids eventually realized that the temperatures in most places have been going up. So what's one possible consequence of temperatures going up? Well, wildfires.
孩子们最终意识到，大多数地方的气温一直在上升。那么，温度上升的一个可能后果是什么？嗯，野火。
This is area in an average year burned by wildfire. They're thinking that it could go way up.
这是平均年份被野火烧毁的面积。他们认为它可能会大幅上升。
That is so not OK.
那实在太不好了。
Yeah, which is not great.
是啊，这不太好。
That hasn't happened to us already.
那还没有在我们身上发生过。
Yeah, because that hasn't happened to us already, jokes one of his students. To some of the kids, the connection between climate and the Camp Fire seemed clear. It was like Kessler was gently guiding them to a better understanding of what they had all just lived through.
“是啊，因为那还没有在我们身上发生过，”他的一名学生打趣道。对一些孩子来说，气候与营地大火之间的联系似乎很清楚。就像凯斯勒在温和地引导他们更好地理解他们刚刚经历的一切。
But not everyone was buying it. This became clear one morning when Kessler asked his class to write out three ways climate change might impact California in the next 50 years. And one of his students, a freckled kid with dimples named Nakowa, says this.
但并不是每个人都买账。这一点在一天早上变得很清楚，当时凯斯勒让全班写出气候变化在未来 50 年可能影响加州的三种方式。他的一名学生，一个有雀斑、有酒窝的叫纳科瓦的孩子，说了这样的话。
You mean this is like global warming stuff? My parents says it's not true.
你的意思是这是像全球变暖那样的东西？我父母说那不是真的。
He says, you mean this global warming stuff? My parents say it's not true.
他说：“你的意思是这全球变暖的东西？我父母说那不是真的。”
Ah, so you're getting mixed messages. I know that must be a little challenging.
啊，所以你得到了混合的信息。我知道那一定有点挑战性。
Kessler pauses for a second, waiting for the class' attention. One kid tells Nakowa that his parents are just wrong. Kessler refers back to the charts he'd shown the kids earlier.
凯斯勒停顿了一下，等待全班的注意。一个孩子告诉纳科瓦他父母是错的。凯斯勒参考了他早些时候给孩子们展示的图表。
Well, what I try to do is just present you with the data. So we're just looking at NASA data and interpreting as best we can.
好吧，我尽量做的就是向你们展示数据。所以我们只是在看 NASA 的数据，并尽我们所能地解释。
Kessler told me later, he uses data from NASA because, even in a polarized America, most people trust NASA. But I don't think the mention of NASA was persuading Nakowa, because he just started quoting his parents.
凯斯勒后来告诉我，他使用 NASA 的数据是因为，即使在美国两极分化的情况下，大多数人也信任 NASA。但我认为提到 NASA 并没有说服纳科瓦，因为他开始引用他父母的话。
They said if it gets hotter, why does it still-- why this year has there been snow in places?
他们说如果变得更热，为什么它仍然——为什么今年在那些地方会有雪？
They said, if it gets hotter, why does it still-- why this year has there been snow in places it hasn't snowed before, Nakowa says? Mr. Kessler just listens. He doesn't argue with Nakowa.
他们说，“如果它变得更热，为什么它仍然——为什么今年在以前没下过雪的地方会有雪？”纳科瓦说。凯斯勒先生只是听着。他不和纳科瓦争论。
Thank you, Nakowa, for sharing. So sometimes, we will learn things that might conflict with what you're hearing somewhere else.
谢谢你，纳科瓦，分享你的看法。所以有时，我们会学到一些可能与你在其他地方听到的发生冲突的东西。
Kessler reminds them that science is about looking at the evidence and interpreting it. His philosophy is to not tell them what to think.
凯斯勒提醒他们，科学是关于审视证据并解释它。他的哲学是不告诉他们该想什么。
It's just discovery. That's what science is.
这就是发现。那就是科学。
Nakowa still looks confused.
纳科瓦看起来仍然很困惑。
I don't know who to believe anymore.
我不知道该信谁了。
I don't know who to believe anymore, he says.
“我不知道该信谁了，”他说。
So do you know that that's what the boys have been learning?
所以你知道孩子们一直在学习那个吗？
Mm-hmm, yes.
嗯，是的。
Have you guys been talking about it?
你们一直在谈论它吗？
We have. We talk about it, because we do not believe it.
是的。我们谈论它，因为我们不相信它。
This is Nakowa's mom, Nancy Kelley. I went to visit them after school the next day. After their house burned, the Kelleys, just like the Wilson family you heard earlier, had to squeeze into cramped quarters-- two parents, three teenage boys, two Boston terriers, an African gray parrot in a one-bedroom apartment.
这是纳科瓦的妈妈，南希·凯利。放学后第二天我去拜访了他们。在他们的房子被烧毁后，凯利一家，就像你刚才听到的威尔逊一家一样，不得不挤在狭小的住处——父母、三个十几岁的男孩、两只波士顿梗犬、一只非洲灰鹦鹉挤在一个一居室的公寓里。
That's where we were. Nakowa sat on the floor. His mom sat on one side of me on the couch, and his dad, Tom, on the other. Tom is a super friendly guy who just does not buy into the idea that humans have caused the climate to change.
我们就住在那里。纳科瓦坐在地板上。他妈妈坐在沙发我的一侧，他爸爸汤姆坐在另一侧。汤姆是一个超级友好的人，他就是不相信人类导致了气候变化。
Science, as far as disaster, our Earth is heading towards this disaster, we're killing ourselves-- that's been around since I was in school. I mean, the soup of the day is climate change.
科学，就灾难而言，我们的地球正走向这种灾难，我们正在自杀——从我上学起就一直存在。我的意思是，今天的汤是气候变化。
Tom tells me he recently heard the former president of the Canadian wing of Greenpeace say that fossil fuels have actually been good for the planet.
汤姆告诉我，他最近听到加拿大绿色和平组织前任主席说化石燃料实际上对地球有益。
Where do you get your information about it?
你是从哪里得到关于它的信息的？
Oh, you pick it up wherever you can pick it up. The ex-president of Greenpeace from Canada, I think that was in a Fox News story. So that's the kind of places we get it from.
哦，你随便在哪里都能捡到。加拿大绿色和平组织的前任主席，我想那是在福克斯新闻的一个故事里。所以那就是我们得到它的那种地方。
It's true. The former president of Greenpeace Canada is one of the rare cases of an environmentalist turned climate denier. He's been invited onto Fox News multiple times. Throughout this conversation, Nakowa was fidgeting, listening to every word we said.
没错。加拿大绿色和平组织的前任主席是环保主义者转变为气候否认者的罕见案例之一。他多次受邀参加福克斯新闻。在整个对话中，纳科瓦一直在坐立不安，听着我们说的每一句话。
The real question is, can you get both sides at school? Is he just going to get the pro? Or are they going to present the con just as eagerly as they present the pro, so that there can be a discussion back and forth? I doubt that happens.
真正的问题是，你能在学校得到双方的说法吗？他是只会得到支持的一面？还是他们会像表现支持那样热切地呈现反对的一面，以便可以进行来回的讨论？我怀疑这不会发生。
I imagine the teacher telling them, this is the way it is, backed by NASA, whatever it is. And then that's the only thing they hear. Did they ever teach you any views opposing climate change? Or was it just, this is climate change, and this is the proof? Or did they say, no, there are some very good people who disagree with this, and this is what they're saying? Did they say that?
我想象老师告诉他们，这就是现状，有 NASA 的支持，无论是什么。然后那就是他们听到的唯一东西。他们有没有教过你任何反对气候变化的观点？还是只是，“这就是气候变化，这就是证明”？或者他们有没有说，“不，有非常有良知的人不同意这个，这就是他们说的”？他们说过那样的话吗？
No. Mostly, what they show us is the numbers. They just show us the charts with all the data on it.
没有。大多情况下，他们向我们展示的是数字。他们只是向我们展示带有所有数据的图表。
For the record, climate change is as settled as science gets. The evidence that humans are warming the Earth is as strong as the evidence that cigarettes cause cancer. And for that matter, the research connecting climate change and fires like the one in Paradise is also sound.
记录在案的是，气候变化是科学界已达成共识的。人类正在温暖地球的证据，和香烟导致癌症的证据一样有力。就此而言，将气候变化与像天堂镇那样的火灾联系起来的研究也是稳健的。
California has always had fires, but the hot, dry conditions that can turn them into mega-fires is on the rise. California had just had five record hot years in a row, and it's also been getting drier in the summer and the fall. That fall, it hadn't rained in Paradise in nearly six months. So when the Camp Fire ignited that November morning, it had no trouble becoming the deadliest, most destructive fire in California history.
加州一直有火灾，但能将它们变成“超级火灾”的干热条件正在增加。加州刚刚经历了连续五个创纪录的炎热年份，而且秋季和秋季也越来越干燥。那年秋天，天堂镇已经近六个月没下雨了。所以当“营地大火”在那个 11 月的早晨点燃时，它毫无困难地成为了加州历史上最致命、最具破坏性的火灾。
Inside the hardware store school, I'd been watching how the science teacher, Marc Kessler, tried to delicately guide his students to an understanding of the issue. He didn't use the phrase climate change right away, didn't deliver any screeds against the fossil fuel industry. He'd been strategic about it.
在五金店学校里，我一直在观察科学老师马克·凯斯勒是如何尝试微妙地引导他的学生了解这个问题。他没有马上使用“气候变化”这个短语，没有发表任何反对化石燃料行业的长篇大论。他对此有策略。
What I hadn't expected was that, meanwhile, parents like Tom and Nancy were deploying their own strategy. They weren't telling their kids to pipe up or contradict the teachers, like Nakowa had done. They didn't want him to get singled out. Better to play the long game.
我没预料到的是，与此同时，像汤姆和南希这样的父母正在部署他们自己的策略。他们没有像纳科瓦那样告诉他们的孩子挺身而出或反驳老师。他们不想让他被单挑出来。最好是打一场持久战。
I believe the opportunity for discussion is past. It's now you believe and we love you, or you don't believe and we hate you. And unfortunately, because of the hate politics surrounding it, we tell him, don't say this to your teachers.
我认为讨论的机会已经过去了。现在是你相信然后我们爱你，或者你不相信然后我们恨你。不幸的是，由于围绕它的仇恨政治，我们告诉他，别对你的老师这么说。
Just find out what you need to learn in the books, and put it down on the test. Don't get into the controversial freedom-of-speech thing where you're going to be hated, and marked, and stuff like that. And unfortunately, that's the reality of our schools today.
只要找出你需要从书本上学的东西，然后在考试上写下来。不要陷入那种会被人恨、被标记等等的争议性言论自由事情中。不幸的是，那就是今天我们学校的现实。
I wondered about Kyson, the kid who loved science class. Kyson's parents are also climate skeptics. They also don't see climate change as connected to their fire. And they also don't want their kid to say any of that in class. Here's Kyson's dad, Brian.
我想到凯森，那个爱科学课的孩子。凯森的父母也是气候怀疑论者。他们也不认为气候变化与他们的火灾有关。他们也不想让他们的孩子在课堂上说任何那种话。这是凯森的爸爸，布莱恩。
I know, Kyson, we've talked to him about stuff like that. And he'll do the work that he needs to do. You have to do the work in the class, and you have to get the grade. It doesn't mean you have to believe in it.
我知道，凯森，我们和他谈过那种事。他会做他需要做的工作。你必须在课堂上做作业，你必须拿到分数。这并不意味着你必须相信它。
So the fire, plus Mr. Kessler's lesson on climate change, had put kids like Kyson in an awkward spot. He's in seventh grade. He loves science. He told me on the first day I met him that he'd learned in Mr. Kessler's class that the carbon in the atmosphere was going up and up, and we needed to do something about it. But after I talked to his parents and he talked to his parents, we spoke again.
所以火灾，加上凯斯勒先生关于气候变化的课，把像凯森这样的孩子置于一个尴尬的位置。他在上七年级。他热爱科学。我见到他的第一天，他告诉我，他在凯斯勒先生的课上学到大气中的碳在增加，我们必须采取措施。但在我和他父母谈过，他也和他父母谈过之后，我们再次交谈。
So it sounds like your parents think one thing, and then you're kind of hearing something different from Mr. Kessler?
所以听起来你父母认为一件事，然后你从凯斯勒先生那里听到的有点不同？
Yeah. It's weird because, at school, it's a big thing, and we could do something to stop it. But then at home, our parents tell us something different. So we don't know what to do. We don't know what to believe and not believe.
是的。这很奇怪，因为在学校，那是一件大事，我们可以采取措施阻止它。但在家里，我们的父母告诉我们不同的事情。所以我们不知道该怎么办。我们不知道该相信什么，不该相信什么。
If you're a kid, who do you listen to on this existential issue? If you trust one set of adults, this issue already radically altered the course of your life. And if you trust another set of adults, it's all just a hoax perpetrated by people with an agenda.
如果你是个孩子，在这个生存问题上你听谁的？如果你信任一组成年人，这个问题已经彻底改变了你生活的进程。如果你信任另一组成年人，那全是带有议程的人实施的恶作剧。
What do you believe?
你相信什么？
I believe both, kind of.
我两者都相信，有点吧。
What caused the fire?
是什么导致了火灾？
I heard it's a power line that went down, and it started to make a big fire.
我听说是一根电线杆倒了，然后引发了大火。
Do you remember Mr. Kessler saying that climate change could lead to higher risk of fires?
你还记得凯斯勒先生说气候变化可能导致更高的火灾风险吗？
Yeah, I do remember that. So I guess it could be really important, because that's kind of what happened. But it happened because of a power line, not a climate change. So that's that.
是的，我记得。所以我想那可能真的很重要，因为那有点像发生的事情。但它是因为电线杆，而不是气候变化。所以就是这样。
It's like Kyson was trying to find some way that they might all be right-- his parents and his teacher, three adults he really looked up to.
就像凯森试图寻找某种方法，让他们都是对的——他的父母和他的老师，他真正仰慕的三位成年人。
Kyson is part of a whole generation born into a world that's already being defined by climate change, but also born into a world awash with misinformation about it. And that means it's possible to learn about climate change in school, to have your whole town burned down in a climate-fueled catastrophe, to see the flames with your own eyes, and still not feel sure about it.
凯森是一个完整的一代人中的一员，出生在一个已经被气候变化所定义的世界里，但也出生在一个充斥着关于它的虚假信息的世界里。这意味着，在学校学习气候变化，让你的整个城镇在气候燃料的灾难中被烧毁，亲眼看到火焰，仍然不确定它是可能的。
Katie Worth, she's the author of the book, Miseducation, How Climate Change is Taught in America.
凯蒂·沃思，她是《错误教育：气候变化是如何在美国教学的》一书的作者。
Well, our program was produced today by Aviva DeKornfeld. The people who put together today's show includes Chris Benderev, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Michal Comite, Andrea López-Cruzado, Chana Joffe-Walt, Seth Lind, Michelle Navarro, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Laura Starecheski, Lilly Sullivan, Jessica Soriano, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu.
好吧，我们今天的节目是由阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德制作的。把今天节目拼凑在一起的人包括克里斯·本德雷夫、苏珊·伯顿、本·卡尔霍恩、达娜·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、米哈尔·科米特、安德烈亚·洛佩兹-克鲁扎多、查娜·乔菲-沃尔特、赛斯·林德、米歇尔·纳瓦罗、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、劳拉·斯塔雷切斯基、莉莉·沙利文、杰西卡·索里亚诺、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、朱莉·惠特克和戴安·吴。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Allison Green, Stephanie Jenkins, Margaret Cargioli of Immigrant Defenders, Mark Steedman, Park Williams, Sophie McKibben, Anna Martin, Sarah Ventre, Austin Fast, David Drexler, and the Paradise Unified School District.
我们的常务编辑是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的高级编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·贝里。今天特别感谢艾莉森·格林、斯蒂芬妮·詹金斯、移民捍卫者的玛格丽特·卡吉奥里、马克·斯蒂德曼、帕克·威廉姆斯、索菲·麦基本、安娜·马丁、莎拉·文特雷、奥斯汀·法斯特、大卫·德雷克斯勒和天堂统一学区。
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 750 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's videos. There's lists of favorite programs, if you're looking for something to listen to. There's tons of other stuff there. Again, ThisAmericanLife.org.
我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.org，你可以在那里完全免费地流媒体观看我们超过 750 集的档案。此外，还有视频。如果你正在寻找可以收听的东西，还有最喜欢的节目列表。那里还有大量其他的东西。再说一次，ThisAmericanLife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. Recently, he's been helping his niece and nephew with their second-grade homework. So sweet. He's so good with them, until they finish up. And then I don't know, his tone--
《美国生活》由公共广播交换机构 PRX 传递给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。最近，他一直在帮他的侄子和侄女做二年级的家庭作业。真甜蜜。他带他们带得很好，直到他们做完。然后我不知道，他的语气——
I got every single question right. I'm the only one that did, I think.
我每一道题都做对了。我想我是唯一一个全对的。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
(SINGING) 'Cause you can't pull the wool over my eyes. Oh, no. You can't pull the wool over my eyes.
（歌唱）因为你不能把羊毛蒙在我的眼睛上。哦，不。你不能把羊毛蒙在我的眼睛上。